then Great Britain the top tax rate was
83% on income if you made an investment
and you add any returns is gonna be 98
percent well as Keith Richards points
out in his in his autobiography says
that was the equivalent of being told to
leave the country well guess what the
Rolling Stones left the country
hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason TV and
today we're talking with John Tammany he
is a writer at Forbes and real clear
markets and he's the author of the great
new book popular economics with the
Rolling Stones
Downton Abbey and LeBron James can teach
you about economics John thanks for
joining thanks for having all right
let's start with LeBron James and work
backwards popular economics the name of
the book you use a dizzying array of you
know kind of anecdotes and sources for
this everything from 19th century
economic text by John Stuart Mill to
things like Downton Abbey Gilligan's
Island I think makes an appearance The
Godfather you name it what does LeBron
James teach us about economics well Ron
James is a reminder that an economy is
not a blob it's just a collection of
individuals and so what do how can
individuals be best off economically
well so I use the bran James as a reason
for having totally open borders to trade
so the first thing what's great about
free trade is it means the most talented
people in the world are vying to sell
you their goods to serve you so that's
good for the individual the individual
is not hurt by cheap goods coming in
from around the world so apply that to
LeBron
well LeBron so what does he do it's
possible that he's a great cook it's
possible that he's great at designing
clothes that he could wear but it would
be at the expense of him being the best
basketball player in the world and so
what is free trade about it's possible
that I can make computers and build the
apartment that I live and what I think I
do best at is write and edit and so I
exchanged the fruits of my labor for all
the things that others are really good
at LeBron James if he didn't just focus
on basketball he wouldn't earn nearly as
much and that's bad for him it's bad for
the rest of us and I mean I guess
there's a case there for not just for
open borders and goods but also in
travel he leaves Cleveland goes to Miami
comes back to Cleveland so you know he's
back in a circuit absolutely I can't
think of a more pure market signal than
where feet go it's easily the purest
market signal on earth and when we
disallow people to move to where they're
most needed we're basically robbing them
of what makes what what what
animates their talents so you're saying
that North Korea really should tear down
the walls and they'll have plenty of
people move maybe yeah
Downton Abbey talk you know explain its
role in the book
well Downton Abbey is an example that
that for what what is the underlying
theme throughout the years of the show
it's about how can we preserve this
estate in most instances from the
government from the Inland Revenue
Service and so one of the things I like
about is they show that the Crawleys
aren't bad people they treat they treat
the people live on the state the state
very well but the bigger picture there
is you think about all the efforts they
have to go just to hold on to their
property from the government and the
people they ultimately have the hire to
protect their property from the
government imagine what those people can
be doing if they weren't protecting
wealth from the government instead we're
creating wealth and specifically just I
think of the getti oil estate it's one
of my major examples in the book the
getty oil state was worth billions in
the 1970s thank goodness the federal
government didn't take all that because
guess what we have ESPN today it was a
joke in the 1970s based on a 10 million
dollar investment of the getty oil state
imagine all the ESPN's we've lost over
the years because government helps
itself to half of people's wealth talk
about you know the concept and this runs
through the book too of creative
destruction because it's well it's true
that like fortunes are often you know
kind of taken away or eaten up by
government and trying to protect against
government it's also true the
technological innovation consumer
demands change and that's suddenly you
know you'll have a you know like a great
company like A&P or you know with Sears
Roebuck or something like that they're
dead now and then you see the rise of
Walmart and Walmart will pass before us
so what are the other forces that you
know destroy destroy and create fortunes
well they're all pretty good ones
because what you're describing is the
experimentation that leads to
replacement one of the things I talk
about in the book is someone's probably
familiar with Blockbuster Video at one
time may rest in peace or whatever at
one time wanted to merge with Movie
Gallery and the Federal Trade Commission
that's infinite wisdom said no no no no
they'll be too powerful in the space
DVDs and videos we can't allow that to
happen well so while they're looking at
that these two companies Netflix comes
in from Silicon Valley and takes them
both out of business and and and and so
the constant experimentation that occurs
in the economy that makes our lives much
better and when you look at next Netflix
in a broader sense what is Silicon
Valley why is it so rich it's because
the vast majority of the businesses
there fail and so with that
experimentation constantly get
perfection and so the underlying message
of the book also is let's leave as much
wealth and capital in the private sector
as possible so that we can have as much
failure as possible let's move it
forward so we can know what the markets
want and also what we didn't know the
markets wanted well you know talking
about the Inland Revenue Department you
know that brings us to the Rolling
Stones who were tax exiles talk about
what the Rolling Stones teach us about
economics well it's a great and also sad
tax story I think we forget how good we
have it relative to about three or four
decades ago back then in Great Britain
the top tax rate was eighty-three
percent on income if you made an
investment and you had any returns is
gonna be 98 percent well Keith Richards
points out in his in his autobiography
says that was the equivalent of being
told to leave the country well guess
what the Rolling Stones left the country
they made one of their greatest albums
ever Exile on Main Street in the South
of France and then finished it up in the
United States and the reminder first of
all is that is that the rich can avoid
top tax rate they've got the means to
get away from them what about the sound
engineers what about the caterers what
about the drivers all the staff that
would have gone into making this in
England they can't move the south of
France they can't move the stones to the
US and so who ultimately pays these
cruel taxes on the most productive it's
those who can who aren't as mobile the
poor in the middle class you know Mick
Jagger went to the London School of
Economics and he was there actually he
overlapped at a period where FA Hyack of
all people was teaching and I often
wonder if they ever met each other or
whatever but it's been you know 30 to 35
years really since the Rolling Stones
have written a song that anybody cares
about you know it I would I would say
like some girls was their land
great out you might have people saying I
know there's a couple in the early 80s
but is the persistence of the Rolling
Stones is essentially the biggest
money-making act every time they go on
tour is that of a sign of market failure
or is that a sign of market success or
what's going on with that I think it's
got to be a sign of market success that
what do people really enjoy let's face
it crave instruction has has competed
away profits on music on the rights to
music what people really enjoy is the
live act and so the Rolling Stones are
giving the markets in fact what they
want which is they want to see these
guys amazing that seems I think in their
70s they want to see them on stage so
it's you know the yeah they don't want
them to make new albums but they do want
to see them perform live yeah they
weren't you have a big enough body of
work and I think the marks are saying we
don't you can't impress that's sad to
say you can't improve on what you had we
want to see we want to see the songs
from some girls in exile and the other
ones alright with popular economics what
is you know who you know how do you want
it to change the world
I think it's tragic that were the
richest country in the world and my
point there is that the US should be
exponentially richer and so the idea
with this is every single American
whether they're well versed and
economics are not intimately understands
economics I think what the profession is
done with charts and graphs has been an
utter fraud all Americans intimately
know the four basics tech anomic growth
if you get taxes regulation trade and
monetary policy right you will have
abundant growth that will make the
present us look poor by comparison my
point is I'm gonna teach it to everyone
through the Rolling Stones I'm gonna
teach it to them through the University
of Michigan football team I'm gonna
teach to them through LeBron James
through the buffalo chicken wings all
they know is right there in front of
them to bring us back to much better
prosperity alright well we'll leave it
there it's a great book and a phenomenal
reading thank you John Tammany thank you
Forbes and real clear markets for
talking with reason TV I'm Nicolas